quem me conhece sabe onde eu chego eu
diga aí é uma boa
boa tarde é uma boa poder uma boa e uma
vez uma pessoa diz flavio por que você
tá sempre chamando pessoal de alma boa
aí eu digo rapaz
veja bem se você chegar o camarada e de
ceaf de guy bicho ruim o há como a gente
diz aqui no nordeste é caba de peia né
liga e caba de peia o cabo vai pensar
assim
mapas do cabo já têm essa essa impressão
minha
e que eu sou ruim do que os outros e
então você aí o contrário quando a gente
cumprimentar pessoas chama de a uma boa
aí a pessoa dizer assim mas eu não vou
poder fazer o mal não quer aquele cabo
tem uma impressão tão boa minha então a
gente no cumprimento que é uma coisa que
a gente faz toda hora nem todo dia com
todo mundo a gente já compromete o cabo
em que no bem né porque a pessoa que não
vou fazer nada errado porque aquele cabo
tem essa impressão que eu sou a uma boa
e assim o dever permanecer então esse é
o sentido da gente também nessa coisa
usual comum que é um cumprimento a gente
propagar o bem bom
então como tema é esse nem aqui pelo bem
eu resolvi trabalhar pensando assim o
que eu poderia fazer
aí eu disse eu vou trabalhar então o
despertar das vocações e porque uma que
é um ambiente universitário eu sei que
vários aqui são são estudantes né oa a
academia que reina nesse nesse ambiente
vamos imaginar é uma hipótese a hipótese
de que se você descobrir o quanto antes
os seus dons pessoais as suas vocações
isso vai fazer toda a diferença na sua
vida ea sua vida é identificada com
esses dois e essa e essas vocações sendo
uma vida boa ela vai poder também
inspirar a influenciar outras vidas
então para comprovar isso eu vou fazer
um recorte da minha vida porque eu
escolhi a minha vida porque
a vida dos outros eu posso de repente é
tem correções onu onu na na apuração da
informação não tem uma percepção correta
do que a pessoa realmente passou
vivenciou e amy não a minha vida ea
minha vida e como diz o ditado boino
lâmina e prime
eu sei falar com o proprietário vou
fazer um recorte então dos 15 aos 55
anos e vou devagarzinho mostrando a
vocês como o despertar é das minhas
vocações fez realmente toda a diferença
em minha vida
vamos começar com o o os x 15 anos o que
é que acontecia quando eu tinha 15 anos
eu estudava no colégio salesiano são
josé além da ribeira porque agora já
existe em outras unidades e tava lá eu
confesso a vocês que eu era super time
do bem diferente do que eu sou hoje
assim acho que eu sou um pouco
desenrolado hoje e eu era tão tempo pra
vocês terem uma idéia de que quando a
professora estava chegando no f da
chamada do flávio ratha me tremendo todo
só para dizer presente no recreio ficava
ali meio meio escondido ali não
interagiu muito com as pessoas e de
repente uma amiga minha chamada vizinha
chegou não sei porquê desse avião faz
sua poesia pra mim
aí eu peguei fiz a poesia e ela pegou
mostrou pra outra amiga e diz a sua vez
também quer uma poesia você fez padre
general eu gostei
aí começou nem as meninas época
mostrando para as outras e todas todas
pedindo todas pedindo e eu descobrir
naquele momento que eu fazia aquilo
muita facilidade não tinha nenhuma
dificuldade de de descrever aquelas
poesias nessa época quando eu falei que
tinha 15 anos
agora mudou tudo era chamado e
científico né
era 1º científico então nesse momento a
gente já tinha que saber mais ou menos
um pra que ia prestar o vestibular
é nessa época
a gente já começava e papai era dentista
e o sonho de papai era que um filho é
viés e dentista como julho já é a
pediatra leila já tinha feito história
já morava em brasília é fernandinho já
tinha feito a da minha administração e
os pequenos não demonstrar essa vontade
eu era louco por papai
aí eu disse vou fazer o dono já mãe que
nada a ver comigo eu até injeção eu
morro de medo de injeção mas logo o
papai mas aí quando eu descobri essa
facilidade para escrever eu fiquei louco
aí comecei a escutar e obviamente
inscrever só mais uma menina aí as
coisas que eu gostava de ecologia aquela
época a nessa idade a reter os amores
assim muito muito forte e se apaixona
loucamente e pegue escrever poesia no
seguinte e fiquei tão boa por pelo ato
de escrever que eu disse não
pelo amor de deus eu vou eu você for
fazer jornalismo papai me desculpe aí
você veja bem jornale naquela época só
tem acho que o diário a tribuna o sinal
da tv vinha de recife era tv pub
a globo também vê um mercado de trabalho
totalmente incipiente né sem futuro como
agente dele mas resolvi fazer é
comunicação você veja bem falando agora
com 55 anos de idade foi a coisa mais
certa do mundo que eu poderia ter feito
um jornalista realizado
trabalhei televisão muitos anos
trabalhei em jornal e escrever adoidado
e até hoje tem um blog aqui eu não sou
leviano está havendo aqui o bichinho
aqui ó
em bonito está bem organizado
a lei acaba aí sim aí empolgado nem
escrever o meu primeiro livro poesia
minha voz minha prima energia hoje eu
tenho 25 livros e ver só tem livro
infantil tem livro de prosa mas eu eu a
poesia como eu disse foi o que despertou
e sídon né
e aqui a velha carteira de estudante
para quem é e 50 e 40 vai vai ser
lembrado
então foi a decisão certa eu
identifiquei
esse dom incorporei ele teve coragem de
seguir porque todo mundo era engenheiro
arquiteto médico naquela época nesse
jornal estadão a doidice e realmente foi
a coisa certa a fazer
aí 15 anos né está aí sim o jornalismo
aí eu eu eu ali com mamãe ali na
formatura linda minha mãe aqui é na tv
tropical entrevistando povo aqui na
cobertura do papa e aqui já um salto
própria o ator atual é o o blog então 15
anos agora vamos pra dez anos depois 25
anos eu já ganhando dinheiro de todo
lado jornalista televisão passei no
concurso da universidade federal babá
aí a minha geração 25 anos com já não
dependem de papai
aí a minha geração começou a se envolver
com drogas experimentação e maconha
cocaína não sei que baba materialismo
extremamente materialista só pensando em
roupa e outros só pelé é experimentado
drogas
os perigos a aparecer no vi aí eu
comecei a me preocupar porque como eu
teve forte influência dos anos 60
pink floyd led zeppelin black sabbath eu
comecei comecei a fumar maconha
depois apareceu cocaína era uma espera
uma coisa aqui outra ali depois um cara
introduzir o disque pó aí ligavam a
cocaína parecia e eu trabalhava na
televisão eu tinha que está no outro dia
é com a voz legal né com a tua cara
vencedor de cocaína ninguém do hmi caiu
de som pela banda que rabo de foguete
banana eu tenho eu tenho que sair de se
definir o negócio não posso ficar nesse
babado não foi aí quando entrou na minha
vida a espiritualidade
eu recebi um livro de uma amiga minha e
na época chamada de haj início depois
foi esse como o chuchu e osho ele dizia
assim a vida flui aqui agora então eu
comecei a ler fiquei doido um erro bobo
demais iria de muito tarde e noite iria
hoje inclusive me apaixonei perdidamente
por uma menina acabou namoro eu vivia no
passado que eu vivi com a menina no
futuro eu ia viver e meninas muito mais
maravilhosas interessantes a conta
aparecendo e eu não passado no futuro aí
ouvi uma história do livro de oxum que
uma monja orava retirada com a mãe ea
buscar água no poço é e era noite de lua
cheia e ela voltando e na rua no reflexo
da lua lhe na lâmina d'água quando
quando ela tropeçou o o homem chama que
o trouxe aquela figura caiu e ela
procurou o reflexo da lua ela tava
olhando está condicionado ainda não viu
que o água o shopping sob água molhou
pra lua real e se iluminou que histórias
em budistas sem iluminações repentinos
ela descobriu naquele instante ela
estava passando a vida olhamos por
reflexos na realidade estava em r no
burro no meu juízo diego pela mudança
aí eu fiquei doida e disse que vai
trabalhar na televisão pib despesa e ver
o carro me mandei pra índia
aí o povo lá de casa de sumir pela oi do
dever a eu já tinha tatuagem já tenha
furado a orelha usá blixen ser
homossexual que era uma revolução só
você opel saab e em cima do praião um
povo dizendo e se mandou pra ainda é é
sem falar em ganhar nem nati e cheguei
na índia praia e mpu a china de bill de
osho no dia 19 de janeiro de 1990 foi o
pisando ainda e hoje morrendo impune
ai o meu amigo diz que eu fui lá só
matar o velho
aí voltei ainda né
e entrei no trecho deixei de deixei que
deixei de beber deixei fumava hollywood
fumar maconha
cheirava bebê agora assina também essas
essa desgraça toda não mais a potência
então com a espiritualidade eu deixei
tudo isso faz uns 20 anos então a disco
esta da espiritualidade e mimi tornou
também uma pessoa melhor
o diabo só de executar e é hoje por 55 e
ainda tivesse perdido na buraqueira só
deixando então assim o envolvimento com
a espiritualidade mi mi harmonizou e o
que aconteceu eu acho que foi o
trampolim pra o passo seguinte que foi
um envolvimento com bem então vamos lá
15 anos e descobriu o dom de escrever 25
anos e descobriu o dom da
espiritualidade
aos 35 anos eu resolvi morar em mãe
luiza estava vivendo um bom momento da
profissão nem ganhando dinheiro de todo
lado
morava na praia do meio aí disse
agora eu vou comprar um terreno e vou e
vou construir a minha casa fui
portalegre escolheu o terreno desse vôo
ou é amanhã eu venho aqui pagar aí na
volta pela via costeira de um negócio na
minha cabeça eu resolvi parar em mãe
luiza não tinha nenhuma ligação para a
mãe luiza não tinha pensado no assunto
foi uma coisa inesperada em maio isaar
ea moto mário que até hoje mora lá bife
para derrubar o então vendendo alguma
casa quitado na sicília e da inclusive
ela tá lindo aceitável lamentou o atleta
ao mesmo preço de r e mails e veja bem
eu seco construir uma casa o lugar onde
você vai morar envolve um pensamento mil
reflexões
eu bebo fund está comprado uma loucura
aí fui construir a casa e mãe luiza
comecei a andar pelo bairro conhecer as
pessoas nessa época não existia sambou
comecei a levar para o hospital arrumar
vaga e maternidade vai começar a
espalhar no bairro aquele menino aquele
jornalista é bonzinho começar a ir lá em
casa pedindo emprego era na época
carreta arrumava emprego sem sem mandar
por recursos humanos como é hoje
por amizade aí comecei a fazer o bem
isso te veja bem sempre
desinteressadamente nunca filho bem
parceiro candidato nem pra nada fui
fazer porque eu acho que eu tenho é foi
a era as coisas né
estavam fluindo era o meu jeito de ser
aí aí o bem foi sendo feito tanto tanto
que minha casa virou a própria casa do
bem
era aí tem uma escola de balada já tenha
um bocado de coisa e e ficou 2 viável a
minha vida porque a portaria já tinha
gente chegar de noite já tinha gente que
houve a necessidade de de levar mais uma
em dizer se moído lá de casa para outro
clube foi quando surgiu a a criação da
casa do bem construímos a casa do bem
através da lei câmara cascudo ou doação
do terreno de ricardo barros ea casa do
bem é assim nada mais é do que um espaço
físico à disposição de pessoas de boa
vontade então se você é da aula de
violão você não vai dar na sua casa na
rua da na casa do bem tudo o que
acontece na casa do bem acontece porque
alguém se disponibiliza a ir lá fazer
porque a região tende em grana tubo foi
o bicho bom para fazer nada é só quando
a pessoa se se oferece então esses anos
todos na casa do bem a gente vem fazendo
é diversas atividades muitas coisas boas
foram foram é possíveis é de fazer lá
escolinha de futebol artes marciais na
área de educação enfim nem tem muito
muita coisa mesmo
então todas essas coisas possibilitaram
é que minha vida ela não se encerrasse
só na minha pessoa
quer dizer há a incorporação dos dons né
a identificação dos dois ea
implementação na minha vida fez com que
a minha vida também pudesse ser
inspiradora para outras pessoas e eu
trouxe pra cá pra exemplificar a oficina
ela deve tá aí
a obra ensina ali é foi a pessoa que o
trouxe para seu exemplo porque durante
toda essa história muitas muitas pessoas
foram inspiradas e a oficina morava em
casa encarcerada com os filhos de mãe
luiza não tinha coragem de sair quando
com advento da casa do bem ela foi pra
lá e até hoje está
a fazendo bem então na pessoa dela eu
exemplifica essa inspiração que a minha
vida pode causar através de todas essas
coisas na pessoa dela quem eu peço a
salva de de paula do nascimento até a
morte
vivemos sempre muitas paisagens temos
dores e prazeres direitos e deveres
nessa viagem eo principal cabe a nós
decidir o rumo certo e eu bem mal você
decide o caminho a seguir natural são
domingos com dele seguir vem a partida
procon final tempo de amor é mais forte
e mais igual
[Música]
o papel
a casa do bem
[Música]
vai ser bom esse nós estamos aqui para o
bem
certamente podemos estar aqui também
para o parabéns porque neste dia tão
especial para mim é o aniversário da
minha esposa hoje do meu filho daqui a
uns dias então para eles que estão ali
uma salva de palmas também e muito
obrigado